[Musique]
nous poursuivons pour l'instant la
présentation d'un certain nombre de
personnalités politiques engagés dans la
campagne électorale aujourd'hui
mademoiselle arlette laguiller qui est
membre du bureau politique de lutte
ouvrière voici son portrait
[Musique]
arlette laguiller 32 ans célibataire
candidate lutte ouvrière dans son
quartier le xviiie arrondissement de
paris
membre du bureau directeur de lutte
ouvrière cette jeune femme est avant
tout une militance son portrait sera
celui d'une militante
l'action politique elle la découverte il
ya douze ans son engagement s'appelait
alors algérie
[Musique]
ouvrière la
famille
l'algérie algérienne arlette laguiller
n'en continue pas moins dans la voix que
lui en tracer ses amis trotskiste et
communistes militer pour moi c'est
cevif consciemment et puis c'est mai
1968 pour elle la fait l'espoir à
l'instant l'aboutissement rêver de huit
années d'un même combat elle milite
alors à voix ouvrière le mouvement est
dissous quelques mois plus tard c'est la
naissance de lutte ouvrière après mais
l'amertume mais aussi la volonté de
repartir sur le terrain dans les usines
dans les bureaux sur les lieux mêmes de
travail
1972 l'enterrement d'un ouvrier maoïste
tué à boulogne billancourt la consolide
dans l'idée qu'elle appartient à une
famille toujours plus grande et toujours
plus ni celle des travailleurs
révolutionnaires
il était important que les
révolutionnaires puisse s'exprimer au
sein de cette campagne électorale je
pense d'ailleurs que si nous n'avions
pas présenté 170 candidats
le rtf ne me donnerait pas huit minutes
d'antenne quand résonne ni candidat ils
sont tous des parents ouvriers
techniciens envoyés chi minh et du
quotidiennement dans leur entreprise qui
sont des militants syndicaux qui
participent aux luttes de la classe
ouvrière
[Musique]
et parmi eux nous présenterons plus de
40 femmes car
les femmes subissent effectivement une
double exploitation la double journée de
la femme c'est pas une formule pour les
élections c'est une réalité quotidienne
c'est que les femmes non seulement elle
se relève peut-être encore plus tôt que
les hommes pour préparer les enfants à
finir le ménage ou ou laver ou repasser
ou faire tout ce que vous voulez
qu'elles ont pas le temps de faire la
veille et quand elle rentre le soir
c'est la hantise de faire les courses de
faire leurs pas voilà c'est ça la vie de
la femme travailleuse et en plus à cela
s'ajoutent tous les problèmes qui sont
liés à la maternité
pompidou ne veut pas régler le problème
de l'avortement pendant les élections
pendant les querelles électorales comme
il dit mais justement nous nous
profiterons des élections pour parler de
ces problèmes là car je me demande
d'ailleurs comment des hommes de la
bourgeoisie peuvent comprendre
l'angoissent la sécurité des femmes qui
ne désirent pas avoir un enfant qui
parce qu'elles n'ont pas d'argent pas de
relation pas de moyen de faire autrement
vont se faire avorter dans des
conditions clandestine dans des
conditions d'hygiène absolument
déplorable où elles risquent leur vie où
elles risquent leur santé le problème
c'est qu'il y avait une grève à
l'origine et avant le soir chez elle
arlette laguiller organise des réunions
où l'on débat des cas concrets ils ont
appris en trente ans que je suis
candidat aux élections législatives
il est évident que dans cette histoire
il cherche à se débarrasser de moi en
tant que militant syndical également
pour mes idées politiques les gens qui
travaillent avec lui ont vécu la grève
avec lui et parce qu'ils ont vécu la
grève avec lui dans le
d'une certaine façon il y en a un qu'on
prend comme tête de turc au moment où le
mouvement commence à être retombé un
petit peu c'est un phénomène classique
qu'on vous qu'on voit un peu dans tous
les mouvements je crois qu'il faut
commencer par sa longue traque de
manière à ce que les gens qui
travaillent avec lui se sentent
concernés par la semaine parce qu'ils
sont concernés en fait dès qu'on
s'exprime dans une entreprise dès qu'on
défend ses idées politiques et bien on
s'expose à être jetés à la porte et à se
retrouver sur le pavé sans salaire les
travailleurs en lutte pour améliorer
leur sort qu démarrage des petits
avantages mais changer complètement la
vie changer complètement la société
donnée aux travailleurs du temps pour
vivre en simplement pour s'user
physiquement et moralement tous les
jours dans les entreprises mais pour
vivre pour s'amuser pour se cultiver
pour lire pour faire du sport pour vivre
quoi pour faire tout ce qu'on ne peut
avoir envie de faire dans sa vie bat
pour ça il ya effectivement qu'un
changement total fondamentales de la
société qui peut permettre finalement la
satisfaction de toutes ces
revendications les révolutionnaires
veulent simplement et bien
réalisé une société socialiste une
société libre je crois que c'est ça et
révolutionnaire en 1973 de la savane non
ce que je voudrais voir celle plus loin
parce que là j'ai l'impression qu'elle
pas beaucoup de blancs à tout petit
rhume des foins
[Musique]
là la société socialiste sera une
société où il y aura pas de police ou
les les sommes qui seront des hommes
libres auront un comportement normal
d'homme civilisé dans une société où
n'existera pas la lutte pour le profit
pour posséder individuellement
un certain nombre de choses chacun
pourra satisfaire ses besoins ce sont
dans les luttes dans les usines dans les
grèves dans les occupations d usines que
c'est là que s'exprime la force des
travailleurs et que ce c'est de cette
façon là effectivement qu'on réussira à
renverser cette société et pas
simplement d'allant déposé un bulletin
dans l'urne parce que il est bien
certain que la bourgeoisie se laissera
pas déposséder de ses privilèges comme
ça et qu'elle en proie à la violence
plus de cent ans après le manifeste
communiste et qu'effectivement les
travailleurs continuent à supporter tout
le poids de cette société à être les
plus exploités à être ce qu'ils
produisent toutes les richesses et qui
n'en profite pas et ça malheureusement
ça n'a pas changé vouloir une société
sans contrainte est ce que c'est un
programme je crois que c'est un
programme c'est le programme c'est le
programme des révolutionnaires depuis
bien longtemps c'est le programme d'une
société socialiste c'est le programme du
parti communiste français son origine
c'est ce que nous défendons la la
dictature du prolétariat effectivement
je crois qu'on peut en parler bon je
répète c'est effectivement la démocratie
la plus large c'est à dire le pouvoir
exercé par les travailleurs
mais si les ouvrières monde elysées
lutte ouvrière
on
lui respectera la constitution demandez
lise et lutte ouvrière
lutte oubliés avec le maguer communiste
révolutionnaire demandez lise et lutte
ouvrière
[Musique]
comment
une colonne qui peut encore y paraît
plutôt friable
il ya l'article sur
/ / marchette semaine c'est quand même
intéressant quand tu sais que marché a
quand même dit qu - la limite
pidoux choisissait comme premier
ministre dire est devant nous à sarlat
veulent quand même les intentions
l'union de la gauche à ce propos dans
une société où les travailleurs au rouge
pouvoir et où la production sera
orientée non pas en fonction du marché
mais en fonction de la satisfaction des
besoins essentiels de toute la
population
effectivement les travailleurs auront à
coeur de discuter de tous ces problèmes
auront à coeur de s'organiser pour en
discuter pour en décider et ça
effectivement ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
au niveau de la défense des intérêts des
travailleurs ou le retrouvera au niveau
de la gestion de la société qu'ils
assurent une société socialiste et si le
soir des élections arlette laguiller se
trouve être élu député
aux problèmes des députés de pouvoir
servir de la chambre comme d'une tribune
oui ça les révolutionnaires
peuvent s'en servir comme d'une tribune
mais il s'agit pas pour nous de gérer la
société bourgeoise
d'accord
le cas de m
[Musique]